[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah ça j'étais pas mal de petits suisses
tu connais mon jour pas jambes et ça va
pas à moi si je peux rien reste
dégueulasse et non merci
c'est chacun le sait comment on va bien
sûr vas-y tout comme le tien
je sais qu'un mémorial
[Applaudissements]
athlète en amérique latine est pas
jared jeunes j'arrive excusez moi je
débute
non mais là rien de rien alors là j'ai
bossé tout le match commence comme
youtube et barreaux
c'est un ami avoue michael absolument
oui
ah bon ah oui ça aussi d'ailleurs je
ferai quand même mais non ça ne veut pas
dire qu on s'est croisé trois fois bon
maintenant 45 ans d'amitié c'est lui
reconnaît qu' il ya chez les artistes
comme chez les gays en un regard on se
comprend les quadras ou pas c'est un
artiste
je vais poser donc des questions sur la
carrière de nos deux invités et sur
leurs poubelles petite merde je vais
venir déféquer dans ton genre 10 h au
lavoir défection quoi rien un sou
j'habite est juste à côté de l'allumer
son spatial bon bah grogne avenue
robert-schuman série les chercher un
extincteur cas où c'est un nouveau
chroniqueur se manifesterait de façon
négative je pense que ce serait pas mal
merci ben merci je vais en chercher un
visa
alors non je regarde jussie marche et
marche
voilà maintenant mathieu tu sais qu'en
tant que tu es allé installer vous pour
la bd mais pas les foules mais crise
heureuse mais l'animateur de cette
démission
si le bonheur qui donne à manger un
petit cap chat ming est passé le travail
ce matin c'est à la gare une fois ci les
hommes c'est dans les yeux tu sais qu'on
t'aime tu seras toujours bienvenu si je
t'aime fort arrête avec ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]